der mann der mich aufregt hat heißt
claus weselsky chef der
lokführergesellschaft gdl ist der größte
ego shooter in deutschland derzeit hat
warum claus weselsky hat es mal wieder
geschafft für fünf tage fahren die
meisten züge und s-bahnen nicht claus
weselsky nimmt damit fast ein ganzes
land in geiselhaft und warum es geht
vordergründig um geld aber mittlerweile
hat die bahn ihr angebot deutlich
nachgebessert und dass die forderung der
lokführergewerkschaft und das was die
bahn bietet unterscheidet sich noch 100
bis 200 euro also sehr sehr wenig am
ende geht es claus weselsky nur um seine
eigene macht und das hat er heute morgen
noch einmal wieder deutlich gemacht
hören wir kurz rein ist also die
zielsetzung des bahnvorstandes ist die
existenzvernichtung der gdl
die bahn will offenbar so glaubt es
claus weselsky seine gdl seine
gewerkschaft also damit auch ihn
vernichten kaputt machen wie auch immer
entmachten und in der tat will die bahn
künftig nicht mit zwei gewerkschaften
verhandeln sondern am liebsten nur noch
mit einer und dann mit der evg und nicht
mit der von claus weselsky also es geht
claus weselsky um seine eigene macht und
nichts anderes und herunter müssen
millionen von pendlern nein das ist
nicht in ordnung das ist ein skandal
also ich bin ja eine dieser pendler und
die darunter leiden ich bin heute fast
nicht zur sendung gekommen wegen des
streiks und natürlich ärgert mich das
sehr und gerade in corinna zeiten musst
du jetzt gar nicht erwähnt hast ist das
natürlich noch viel dramatischer weil
natürlich die züge die fahren dann top
ten voll sind und wir reden hier seit
anderthalb jahren darum dass wir uns
schützen müssen und da ist dann
plötzlich okay dass man tagelang die
züge dicht macht und so viel stau
vermeidet andererseits also ego-shooter
naja er kämpft für ja sehr sehr viele
mitarbeitende aber wie gedacht dass die
bahn ihr angebot deutlich nachgebessert
das heißt klaus wie selbst gefordert 3,2
prozent auf 28 monate die bahn hat jetzt
geboten 3,2 prozent auf bis zu 36 monate
claus weselsky will eine corona prämie
von 600 euro die bahn hat jetzt geboten
zwischen 400 und 600 euro also die
unterschiede sind nicht mehr sehr groß
es geht hier wirklich um reine macht und
wir haben den beitrag ja gerade gesehen
es geht ihm um seine macht er ist der
ego-shooter und erneut mit seiner macht
weil lokführer natürlich in der lage
sind ein land halb lahmzulegen kann er
das machen ich finde aber spannend zu
sehen dass man was tun kann und dass man
für seine rechte als arbeitnehmerinnen
und arbeitnehmer kämpfen kann
klar schwierig wie gesagt geradezu chor
unter zeiten ich bin selbst betroffen
ich finds auch nicht toll aber ich finde
es sehr spannend zu sehen was die
damalige
situation du hast gesagt du bis hierhin
gekommen vermutlich mit dem auto was dir
vermutlich direkt zur verfügung stand
das ist natürlich was anderes es gibt
natürlich auch menschen die haben das
auto nicht direkt vor der tür die können
nicht dann mit dem automatischen
hinfallen deren mobilität ist sehr sehr
eingeschränkt und der ist muss ich sagen
bin ich hier komplett bei jan ego
shooter ist genau das richtige wort ich
bin jetzt sehr gespannt es wird jetzt
geklagt und ich bin da total auf der
seite der deutschen bahn heftige wind
die die frage die ich so stand ende ist
es sehr wunderbar hat jetzt seinen bogen
in der hand und den hat er gespannt dumm
ist nur auch für die leute für die er
kämpft in der bogen überspannt wird weil
wir nicht den bogen nicht mehr sparen
kann jedoch kein pfeil rein und dann hat
er nichts mehr im köcher und das wäre
nun wirklich auch wahnsinnig druck du
sagst sie sind relativ nah beieinander
und immer diese ständige nein nein nein
ich will alles alles alles ist nicht der
richtige weg meiner meinung nach wenn
zwei parteien auseinander liegen da muss
man sich schlecht geraten irgendwann mal
finden das gerichtsurteil ist natürlich
super spannend in deutschland mit so
starken gewerkschaften wenn da jetzt
wirklich der bahn recht gegeben wird
würde ich mal gespannt was das auch für
eine signalwirkung für alle anderen hat
jan fleischhauer hat heute aber ich will
dass die tat nicht wegnehmen würde ich
ist als würde ich diesen klugen gedanken
gehabt ich finde aber so ein kluges
obwohl das in der politik mittlerweile
immerhin noch ist die weise euro an
dogan immer und ich möchte jetzt das
computerhirn fleisch wir machen er hat
ihn heute mit einem erpresser verglichen
und dass er diesen beruf ja nicht dann
seinen kindern empfehlen möchte
lokomotivführer erpresser ich finde das
ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so schlecht den
vergleich in dieser form den erpresser
reinzubringen jacobi wie ist das denn
eigentlich sie kommen aus der schweiz da
fährt man auch gerne bahn für bahn gibt
es da so was ähnliches wie ein claus
weselsky nein für mich dass wir würden
wenn sie seien claus weselsky gäbe
würden wir den segen als exportprodukt
[Gelächter]
habe ich mir ein begriff geschrieben
dass ich konnte den nicht vor ich bin
jetzt aber schon länger nicht mehr
männer deutschen bahn gefahren
das ja auch schwer zeit ist im moment
schwierig aber das geht natürlich etwas
tiefer hier und jan fleischhauer hat
recht diese weselsky ist jetzt der
typische
gewerkschaftsvertreter in dem sinn dass
eben gewerkschaften heute tatsächlich
erpresser organisationen sind und ich
habe da ein sehr kritisches verhältnis
und ich muss jetzt vielleicht meinen
anwalt beiziehen was ich da sah ich weiß
gar nicht was in deutschland noch sagen
darf darf man sagen ja ich finde eben
gewerkschaften etwas hoch
problematisches und dieser weselsky man
merkt es nicht dass die hybris der macht
ego shooter ist ein guter ein guter
begriff und der versucht jetzt einfach
hier das auszureizen bis ans letzte und
das ist eben diese erpresserische
funktion die frage die man sich stellen
muss ist die was bringen denn diese
gewerkschaften am schluss überhaupt den
leuten kann man das überhaupt nachweisen
dass das einen produktiven nutzen ob in
der schweiz zum beispiel haben wir
weniger starke gewerkschaften weniger
streik tage wir haben einen freien
arbeitsmarkt und ich habe immer plädiert
auch als auch in den usa noch in
deutschland war das man einfach etwas
die macht der gewerkschaften zurück
nimmt und diese herr weselsky ist für
mich jetzt einfach typisch die die
arroganz und selbstüberschätzung einig
dann auch der gewerkschaften und so
gesehen hat fleischer oder ich mir zeit
mehr als begriff ich habe eine frage
vielleicht könnt ihr das alle mir
beantworten weil ich weiss es nicht ist
rwe selbst die eigentlich mit seiner
meinung allein oder teilte das liebe
leute für die für die er kämpft sagen
die eigentlich auch kämpft bis zum
update es gibt ungefähr es gibt ungefähr
knapp 40.000 mitglieder bei der
gewerkschaft gdl also bei der
lokführergewerkschaft und dann gibt es
die evg die eisenbahn und
verkehrsgewerkschaft dies mehr als
viermal so groß die vertritt auch die
interessen der bahnangestellten als ist
ja nicht so als wenn man jetzt ohne die
gdl plötzlich gar keinen
gewerkschaftlichen mehr schutz mehr
hätte bei der bahn sondern natürlich
werden da auch arbeitnehmerrechte dann
gewerkschaftlich vertreten der punkt den
roger köppel macht er ist glaube ich
sehr spannend die frage was bringen
gewerkschaften eigentlich oder nicht
interessant ist ja wenn man sich einmal
tarifkämpfe anschaut wo man denkt mensch
da geht der gewerkschaft daraus jetzt
kämpft er für die arbeitnehmer
interessanterweise laufen die eigentlich
immer nach dem gleichen muster erst geht
ein gewerkschaftschef raus und macht das
angeboten die arbeitgeber machen gar
nicht stellen sich tot dann ist schon
mal also kommt man in brass dann kommt
die zweite runde da legen die
arbeitgeber in der regel ein angebot vor
das weisen die gewerkschaft sei mit
empörung zurück unverschämtheit so läuft
es immer dann kommt die dritte
tarifrunde
dann wird das arbeitgeber-angebot in
gewisser weise nach gewässern kommt mich
die ersten warnstreiks kann man alles
lesen läuft in der metallindustrie
beispielsweise immer wieder gleich wir
sehen es ja bei der
lokführergewerkschaft auch das heißt es
geht hier um ein drehbuch und das ist
interessant deswegen was sie sagen geht
es wirklich immer um die arbeitnehmer in
essen oder geht es nicht eigentlich um
den showkampf der gewerkschaftsboss
scorsese ist ein schon kommt bei uns
gesehen bei firmen zb früheren
daimlerchrysler und ist außen aufgabe in
deutschland haben die gewerkschaften
jahre lang den damals unfähigen so fremd
im amt gehalten haben ja
kapitalvernichtung betrieb im ganz
großen stil aber der hat dann immer mit
den gewerkschaften schön lässt sich zwar
gut und gemacht und ich weiß nicht was
haben sich zusammen ins bett gelegt dann
ist das so geblieben die gewerkschaften
hatten die tolle geschichte in wolfsburg
hatten wir diese betriebsrats feste das
ist ja die das waren ja geradezu
korruptions räte damals in wolfsburg und
das zeigt einfach die dekadenz der
gewerkschaftlichen bewegung die
ursprünglich ganz ursprünglich meine
sympathien hat aber das was daraus
geworden ist ist eine karikatur die zum
teil ganz direkt gegen die interessen
der arbeitnehmer arbeiter das sehen wir
jetzt da die wenn der das beste resultat
ich kenne die details nicht das beste
resultat da schlägt und eine andere
frage haben noch gar nicht diskutiert
liegt zu der comic langeveld streben die
gewerkschaften sind doch oftmals auch
die die in einer firma die ganz guten
und die begabten und die
leistungsfähigen zurücknehmen weil das
quasi das kollektiv dann wieder unter
druck setzt auch mehr zu leisten das
sind also nivellieren de
organisationen mit erpresserischen
ambitionen das muss man sehr kritisch
sehen was hier passiert
[Musik]